hi everyone it's jerry let's have a look
at a game from round three of the 2022
tata steel masters tournament
on the white end daniel dubov and he's
paired against vidiq
gujarati there are a few takeaways for
me from this game this italian game
a late opening idea i found interesting
some middle game ideas
we also get to see
a king get some exercise vidit's king
not only goes uncastled but goes for a
walk
in this one these are always
entertaining games to go through
so the first moment to speak of i guess
is this move six by black
h6
questioning the bishop when exactly when
the king is uncastled
bishop of course maintains the pin
and we do this because
if at some point one we want to break
the pin with g5 this committal g5 move
uh
it's less likely the knight sacrifice on
g5 will be working for white
because the king still maintains the
option to
find shelter
on the queen side
from here
a5
an ambitious decision with the a pawn
the computer will also point out a6
both of these moves
have something in common they are
vacating
a7 for the bishop
in anticipation of d4 that's a nice
fallback square
c3
is prep work for d4 so
we can expect this move at some stage
additionally a5 is not allowing white to
grab queen side space so easily
with b4 there's a grip over that point
um why wouldn't everybody play a5 it's
because this is now a bit more weakened
maybe bishop b5
or even the queen knight one day getting
into
b5 uh can be a problem for white or a
problem for black
after this move knight a3 the move
played in the game this was one of the
thoughts that ran through my mind i'm
like oh all right
see this black wants to be more
ambitious maybe
i'll try to be a pest one day with my
knight on b5
it's not the only
idea white has in mind with the knight
on a3
um
getting into b5 but we also have this
typical
e3 square in mind
knight a3
it's just an
atypical way to get into e3 most
more common is by way of d2 f1
and e3 both requiring three tempe forget
all of that
when i started the video saying that
there is uh
a late opening idea that i found
interesting this is that moment
uh vidit's decision now in move eight
bishop takes knight so
an imbalance early on in this out of
this italian game
if you're gonna give up the bishop for
night you better justify in some way
what is black saying
i've compromised your queen side
structure
now
i'd like to throw white's queen side
structure under the microscope for a
minute
i don't want to just stop there and say
it's a compromise queen side structure
i'd like to point out
that because of this exchange a3 a4 and
c3 are now holes
but
i'm not really seeing those three
squares as
squares let's say black knight could get
to and
be a pest to white
i'm more so drawn to white's d-pawn
since white doesn't have a b pawn around
the d3 pawn is the one that's going to
is the only pawn now around
that can control
c5
now the c5 squares is a very important
square to keep control over because
well once this pawn gets to d4
it probably needs to stay there
if if ever there's a capture or a push
c5 would then become a hole and a black
knight getting into that square would
not just be a best piece for black but
probably best piece in the position it's
that strong of a piece
so
i could say
what's the justification for giving out
the bishop for a knight i could say
white
has a compromise queen side structure or
maybe the more detailed view is there's
now a greater restriction placed on
white's
d3 pawn
it probably needs to go to d4 and stick
around there for some time
one final note
what bishop was just exchanged for the
knight
black's bad bishop
if in one of your own games you're using
your good bishop to take out a knight
you probably need an additional reason
to support
that decision
okay from here queen e7
castles
proceed with caution
knight v8 black is already
underdeveloped
in this position and is taking another
step backwards for what reason well he
wants to connect knights
this is a maneuver you will often see
uh out of the rui lopez the briar
variation has this maneuver
in that briar variation you're also
looking to have the c pawn contribute
i'm not so sure that's the case in this
environment with this imbalance present
it's more so to have the knights one day
connected
so this is nearby
as i start started out in the beginning
of the video i i said that black went
uncastled if black wants to castle in
this game he can
safely
um
i'd like to highlight this variation
instead of the underdeveloping
plan
uh computer points out g5
b6
and fiance
has the correct uh you know structure
and bishop are coordinated well
and
nearby queenside castles
how can white maybe interfere with this
setup
uh let's say bishop b5 this isn't quite
working out for white because after
queenside castles
an idea to swipe the knight
and then win out on e5 would not be
working
because after the pawn recaptures
there's a timely attack against the
queen
and black is able to defend here in time
soon
this structure will kill these two
miners
i'm also
going down this line here because
we get to see this knight on c5 will
soon be
a best piece
okay anyhow you could go forward with
breaking the pin
and a quick queenside castles
okay from here knight b8
d4 sure enough knights are connected
rook b1 half open file and pop quiz
black to move here i'll
i'll give you a multiple choice question
what move would you play here
we have this pin how do we get out of it
your choices are
g5
or
knight f8
with next up knight g6 attacking the
bishop
which move would you play
this one or this one feel free to pause
the video
okay
in the game it is g5
there's a big problem with knight f8
this was one of the instructional
moments for me from this game
i am more
positionally
minded yeah i'm more positionally minded
and i'm not
normally so quick to make these
committal decisions with b5 uh with g5
excuse me creating uh you know these
holes on f5 and h5
uh there's a problem with this
positional approach
knight f8 g6 and then castles king side
what is the issue
this is the issue
knight takes e5
this is a really strong variation for
white
um after pawn takes knight
white can follow up with f4 and e5 is
collapsing there's still this pin
big problems for
black what do you do either capture on
f4 or d4
is met with e5 and you're getting the
piece back while also
opening up the position
so
that's a problem
if let's say g5
e takes f6
you know if there's this check you're
not getting the bishop because the
bishop can block on f2
what other variation to maybe test out
here let's say in this position instead
of either capture you play knight g6
there's bishop takes knight
queen takes bishop f takes towards the
center queen is hit f7 is collapsing
big problem there for black
if you take with the pawn
you still take here
and there's going to be a problem on the
the f-file squares
one way or another
take with the pawn bishop takes f7
uh if you take with the knight this is
considered best
and queen takes e5
this is an excellent position for white
okay
one final variation i guess would be g5
and after
these chops and this one the pin is
maintained
how we getting out of this
it's not easy
okay
important to see this tactical shot on
e5 in short this maneuver
given enough time
may be something to consider but it's
not quite working out here in the game
g5 bishop g3
knight takes e4 queen c2
what do you do what do we do about this
pressure against the knight
f5 or knight takes bishop
why not i'll throw another pop quiz your
way which of these two would you play
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go move plane in the game
f5
computer notes that you could go ahead
and take the bishop
straight away but i could see why you
know
a human player would not want to
take the bishop so fast
if knight takes bishop in this position
white will
you know violate the principle that says
take towards the center with the pawns
you know he's going to take away in this
case and now there's
there's an accident that's likely
there's an accident that's likely going
to happen on f7
so for example let's say knight here
opening up the bishop
could take on f7 this is not winning for
white
but it's certainly scary these moves
here that's like an only move for black
says after queen e2 this position is
equal
okay anyhow
not so fast to open up this file for the
rook note the timing of this capture in
this game first it's f5
pawn takes pawn
black recaptures with the pawn
if you take with the knight first
the bishop gets to take this knight
doesn't have a way out
in taking the bishop one day
also
rook b5 as a follow-up
is problematic
what are we doing about this e5 pawn
how do we stop this
c5
now there's rook e1 there's probably a
sacrifice nearby maybe even some
undermining move like g4
trying to win the knight outright
all of the white pieces are functioning
and we still have these guys
on the back rank
so
it's important not to take
with the
knight in this position
in the game with the pawn
so now if rook b5
we can play here
rook takes pawn we have that covered
so after pawn takes
and rook e1 only at this point
does the knight go ahead and take the
bishop
uh there is not going to be the
coordinated pressure on f7 in this case
white takes towards the center
e4 follows
this pawn is in a pin
this is not a threat just yet
g4
a doubled pawn often an expendable pawn
g4 looking to break down this structure
knight c5
knight d4
and rook to f8
some support necessary over
f5
from here pawn takes
bishop takes
and can you spot do bob's
next to move
feel free to pause the video
okay considered a best move move played
in the game
rook takes b7
sharp play
typical of dubov
uh what is the idea behind this move
here the knights do go backwards that
rook can be captured
but it shouldn't be captured
um the move played in the game is rook
f6
what's the issue with knight takes rook
the issue would be bishop b5 check
now what does this king
do you move with the king
to d8
that's gonna hurt
a fork and the queen is lost
if you block with the bishop
a skewer
queen is once again going to be lost
and your only other option
is pretty much to run
to f7
but then the bishop would fall and this
knight is hardly worth
only three points
probably
at least worth the rook
especially with queens still aboard
in the king super vulnerable
so
poison rook
the best move was the move played in the
game nice defense here
by vidit with rook f6
this controls c6
no knight jump there
and also vacates f8 for the king
so new square is produced
maybe g7 is one of the more secure
squares for the black king
from here queen b1
defense of the rook while still
maintaining pressure on e4 maybe even
there's a queen
pivot on b5 for a check
only at this stage only after f8 is
vacant
do we have knight takes rook
queen takes knight
rook d8
knight takes bishop
rook takes knight
rook takes pawn what are we doing about
this skewer
what move would you play here feel free
to pause the video
a lot of pop quizzes thrown your way
it's three too many
okay here we go
rook d1 very important detail
uh if
you immediately block
you will lose
let's see why
let's see why it's important to have
this move inserted first if you
immediately block
on this move 25 you lose in the
following way
queen c6
and now what would black's options be
we can forget about the queen trying to
block in
these ensuing lines she already has one
responsibility for as long as this
tension between the rooks remain
if you give her a second responsibility
you're asking for trouble you're gonna
lose a piece one way or the other
so let's consider first the king move
what's wrong with king f8
that's met with this check
another check
and there goes the rook next move
let's consider the rook block
we have another check
if king f8
that's mate
got that one covered
and
if we go in this direction well now
after this check
the black queen is forced to block and
we can take the rook straight away queen
takes bishop takes we're up the piece
so why is it important to first insert
the check
and only then play rook e5 ah
d8 is vacant
after queen c6 the move played in the
game the king can and should go
to d8
queen on a8 check king d7 only move
bishop check
here's the walk
king e6 this is an even position
another check king f6 another check king
f5
both players are pretty much in blitz
mode they're under
10 minutes each
from here f3 this is
the losing move for white
uh considered best for white here
is returning with the queen to c8
this move can be played without fear of
king takes rook
because
an aesthetic finish would follow
in the following way
maintenance iii
check
only move
check only move
mate
that would be a cool sequence uh black
has plenty of time to work out that
detail i don't i wouldn't expect black
to take the rook if queen c8 was played
in the game we had f3
rook takes rook
pawn takes rook
king recaptures another check king
marches forward still
bishop c6
black queen improves
g3 the only other option was king h3
but that would allow rook h1
and now there are three different mates
rookmate
queen mate
i'd probably go with the pawn mate
okay in the game
g3
g4
no peace moves
a new square is opened up for the queen
mate and two threat in the corner
from here queen a7
king d2
the walk is over
white resigns there's no good follow-up
here
these two ideas are still present
how do you stop them
you know you could
go here with the queen but a queen
exchange is the same as resigning
you know this is completely dead for
team white
so
uh an interesting game in this one no
good follow-up uh for white
uh some cool
you know that late opening idea to give
up the bishop for night and
yeah keep in mind that little maneuver
of knight f8 to g6 that sacrifice on e5
uh that was probably the main takeaway
for me
in this game that's uh something i could
very easily see myself falling for so
anyhow feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below i hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you